did Florida accidentally ban Shakespeare
a Tampa Florida school district told
teachers they can assign the full play
Romeo and Juliet
why among other concerns administrators
were worried that some parts of the play
violates a Florida law that prohibits
schools from teaching materials that
describe sexual conduct so the parts of
the play that deal with sex like this
and the domain
there and
there and this women being the weaker
vessels are ever thrust to the wall
could end up being off limits the State
Department of Education insists that
their law doesn't apply to classic
literature like Romeo and Juliet but the
thing is laws like these can have
unintended consequences when schools
fear legal backlash a loss supposedly
designed to keep explicit books away
from high schoolers absolutely can keep
them away from a lot of classic
literature too